[Music]
we never consider ourself gay we're for
my finger to us because we never go
having sex with another for fluffy knee
we only go for straight men it's a
puzzle to outsiders how far Feeney have
the body of men yet identify as female
and have sex with men but are not gay
the key to this puzzle is in the bonds
that tie simone society together gender
roles even sexual desire is shaped to
suit society that means gender identity
is often hugely shaped by culture being
a woman in Samoa is quite different from
being a woman in Western society for
Samoans
the group the village and extended
family is more important than the
individual and your role in that group
decides your gender more than your
individual Anatomy act like a woman and
the group will consider you a woman
which is why sex between a 15 e and a
man is regarded as a heterosexual
relationship but the main reason falfa
Feeney are not considered taboo is
because society sanctions their very
existence by deciding their child lives
as a father Feeney a family gives them a
place and a role in the all-important
group in Samoan society
I was raised but I was raised by my
grandmother as a 15 year
most of the family over here in
somewhere they have at least one or two
farthing in the family my family it's
about seven or more we still see some
younger ones coming up and and nobody
can stop it
but not all young boys willingly submit
to life as a 15 II this third gender is
often welcomed and extended families
because falfa Feeney play a useful role
in household labor their male bodies
provide extra muscle power
work roles are clearly defined by gender
in Simone society domestic tasks are
regarded as women's work
and when there are not enough girls to
help around the house often the only
answer is to raise a male child as a
girl to do these chores buffa Feeny
consider themselves better than men or
women at domestic skills if you cook
with a fire thingy I think I think it
will be better than you if you're
claiming or doing all those kind of
stuff that a woman should do
Rafi egg is better than a woman do it
for doing it